levantar una Italia en declive este es
el objetivo declarado de la alianza
conservadora que se impuso en las
elecciones legislativas del domingo se
compone de tres partidos hermanos de
Italia de Georgia meloni la liga de
Mateos albini y Forza Italia de Silvio
verlos Connie pero la gran ganadora es
ella Georgia meloni y su partido
postasista que se sitúa claramente por
delante de la coalición de 45 años
exministraré verlos Connie confundó
hermanos de Italia en 2012 en los
últimos cinco años el partido ha
multiplicado por 6 el número de sus
simpatizantes
ultraconservador defiende la llamada
familia tradicional y lucha contra los
derechos
lgbtimás con un sentido identitario es
decididamente ante inmigración y
multiplica sus posiciones
situado en la extrema derecha del
espectro político hermanos de Italia es
considerado Incluso como post fascista
la perspectiva de que melón y se
convierta en primera ministra preocupa
en Bruselas soberanista crítica
regularmente el debilitamiento de las
fronteras y quiere poner a los italianos
en primer lugar el programa de su
partido parece haber conquistado a una
parte creciente de la población causados
de la inestabilidad gubernamental y
afectados económicamente por la pandemia
del covid 19 al superar a sus aliados de
La coalición Georgia meloni está en
buena posición para asumir la
presidencia del Consejo de ministros
siempre que el partido populista
movimiento 5 estrellas no se alinee con
el partido democrático